is your own sweet Canadian guy who was a
contestant on Canadian Idol called will
blunderfield just got off the phone with
him and I just thought what a sweet
young man but drinks his own and not
just his own pics as it turns out
there's a whole video where he's like
and it's got a little bit of pre-cum in
it and we had a long discussion about
whether or not it was just simply too
unpleasant a phrase to be airing on
Radio 4 when people might be having
their breakfast we decided we're going
to keep it in
how did you get interested in thinking
about modern gurus
I wonder where the inspiration kind of
came from but I I think I've always been
a journalist who's been interested in
the weirder parts of the internet so
I've spent a lot of time I remember
early in the 2000s um when I just come
out of being a teenager I spent a lot of
time in body modification communities
there was a site called BM ezine which
was um run by a kind of crazy Canadian
called Shannon Lara and it was all full
of either people having these really
weird experimental tattoos and piercings
or actually in quite a lot of cases like
hammering nails through their nuts
um so from the very start my interaction
with the internet was a lot about being
in the kind of weirdest spaces and I've
always really enjoyed reporting on
subcultures so it does feel kind of
slightly strange to me that I'm right at
the end of my 30s and I'm still doing
like let's explain the internet to
people
um you know and I thought we might have
got past that by now but it is still a
it is still a viable job in journalism
and a really fun and interesting job in
journalism okay and gurus are now their
own subculture many multiple subcultures
on the internet in your opinion well
every sort of I think pretty much every
interesting sphere on the internet has
its own set of gurus and there are lots
that I didn't get to in the series you
know parenting is a really interesting
one right I think when people are at
moments of precarity or anxiousness they
want someone to tell them what to do or
want someone to assure them that they've
been through the same thing
um and you know more and more of our
connections are moving online my big
analysis of the last 20 years is we used
to have these Geographic communities you
know you used to have to be friends with
whoever lived in your town and that's
moved much more to most of our
socializing based around interest
communities and so what you have is that
you might not know the people who live
on your street but you know all the
other furries or whatever it might be I
know that there are any fairy gurus I
should just clarify that I'm sure there
are but I don't personally know of them
but you know parenting or Wellness or
productivity or whatever it might be all
the bits of your life whether it's
dating or working money making who do we
look to for advice now actually
sometimes it's our friends but just as
often it's someone on the internet
I suppose
as soon as you allow people to choose
their own subculture whatever it is that
one person is going to get obsessed by
and find interesting or compelling or
whatever
there is inevitably going to be a person
that is most effective at capturing the
attention of the people who like that
stuff and they are then going to have
incentives that align to encourage them
to give out advice sometimes those
incentives could be Financial other
times they could be genuinely altruistic
here is a unique medical condition that
very few people have dealt with and I
have actually managed to find out a way
that the medical system hasn't seen and
here here is a potential solution for
you and then people are going to hail
them and everything in between from
useful to useless
yeah I mean childbirth and NCT groups
right National childbirth groups are a
really interesting example of that in
the real world which is that people who
have just had a baby are just about to
have a baby want a huge amount of advice
and their friends aren't necessarily
going through the same experience at the
same time and sort of aren't that
interested so they seek out these
childbirth groups however if you ever
have a friend who goes through that
process get ready for them to complain
about the fact that there will be lots
of you know people creeping into that
hillbeat for example you know very
anti-bottle feeding for example or might
have very odd opinions on childhood
vaccines and yeah as you say there is
always the problem of the kind of the
kind it's like the sound of I won't
don't want to be a member of any club
that would have me kind of thing right
anybody who wants to be listened to by
definition you should probably be quite
suspicious of
um because those people you know like
narcissists self-select very heavily
um where did the gurus come from then is
it a natural emergence in your opinion
or are the people seeing the opportunity
to jump on the back of a bandwagon how
many of them are altruistic versus how
many of them are
um pre-prepared looking at this as an
opportunity to give make a name for
themselves
people who try and reinvent themselves
across a number of different domains so
one of the people we talk about episode
six is about something called Day game
which is a pickup artist technique where
you chat up you're smiling in the way
that implies you've already had an
interaction with this community but for
those who haven't
um you know you try and pick up women on
on the street and get them into bed very
quickly and one of the guys who was very
big in this in the 2000s late 2000s
early 2010 was a guy called Tom Torero
and it was interesting talking to people
who'd known him before he was Tom Torero
when he was a guy called Tom rawlish he
was at Oxford he was a fairly nerdy
percussion student but he had been very
much like a new atheist debate bro
um and he then he'd completely fallen
out of love with that and he'd become
very religious and he went and actually
interviewed Richard Dawkins and felt
that he'd really smack Richard Dawkins
down and that made me laugh because in
the previous episode about the IDW I'd
spoken to James Lindsay now James
Lindsay is I think let me get this the
right way around I think his middle name
is actually Stephen but his pen name is
James a Lindsay because he started out
as a new atheist writer in the American
South again in the new atheist wave
does that make sense and like the A and
the S are next to each other on the
keyboard so this was his like Superman
Clark Kent level of Disguise about who
he really was but he started out as a
new atheist and now he's you know funded
by Christian conservatives and you know
you could see someone like Majid Noah as
another member of the IDW right starts
off in his book to hear an islamist
organization then because you know is
now a kind of big anti-vaxxer and I
think some people I call it like after
the bacteria I call them extremophiles
you know they're just very attracted to
these big intellectual movements
whatever's the kind of zeitgeisty thing
now and being a kind of thought leader
in it and that's interesting to me
because I think most people probably
have more fixed opinions and want to
succeed in that sphere whereas there are
some people who are who like the need
comes first the need to be validated the
need to be listened to the need to be
important comes first and then they pour
themselves into all the different
bottles and see which one feels like the
best fit did you consider looking at
Brian Rose from London real
I did not tell me about Brian Rose from
London rail you've missed a trick so
Brian Rose is I would say the most
successful serial grifter on the
internet
um or perhaps the most unsuccessful
given the fact that everybody knows it's
a grift as you say the fact that you're
calling him a grifter indicates but
things have not gone well for Brian
razor blade if there was a he's had a
sort of 50-year face plant basically
just permanent every birthday it's just
some new grift and it's failed again
um he started off doing podcasting a
long time ago maybe 10 years ago
basically him and his business partner
were watching uh Joe Rogan they really
liked it they decided to do their own
thing
um this only just recently came out but
he kind of screwed the business partner
over took the project for his own
he starts doing this business he then
gets introduced to Dan Pena the trillion
dollar man who as far as I can see is of
just a loud angry sweary grumpy old dude
that wears suits and big ties that look
like something from Mad Men
he ran for the mayor of London he
created his own independent Freedom
platform so he could broadcast live
streams with David Ike during the middle
of covid he uh is now doing
decentralized Finance defy like things
and is republishing podcasts that he
recorded
four or five or six years ago to make it
look like the people who used to have
honor coming back on so that they still
think that he's relevant
it's impossible to unsubscribe from his
email list anybody that's listening to
this do not subscribe to his email list
because that is like the worst venereal
disease that you can think of it's just
never getting off you and
like this this is the Chris Williamson's
gdpr complaints section of the podcast
correct that's very correct yeah I God
if I could so if I knew how to submit to
gdpr Brian would be I mean I'm behind a
very long list of people that have got
grievances with him my point being
every single different opportunity that
has come up where there has been a
chance for him to inject himself into
something that looks opportunistic
um there's always a financial incentive
there's always an in-group out-group
tribalism thing going on it's them
versus us they're trying to shut down
free speech or they're trying to tell us
what to do they're not for the people in
politics they're trying to control your
money each one of them has got the same
like Cadence and Rhythm and fundamental
feel to it
and yet he just can he one of them fails
he got less votes in the London mayoral
election than that guy that has the bin
on his head
he got fewer votes than that guy
um
got told off because he was going around
London in a bus that had his face on the
side of it live streaming from the bus
as he was going around and then the
police came over and said you can't do
this it's [ __ ] lockdown he said as
you can see the current mayor of London
is trying to stop our campaign I'm like
Brian you're not being victimized you're
just a prick like that's what's going on
um honestly I would like to say that to
her I would say approximately four
percent of the internet need to be told
you're not being victimized you're just
an [ __ ] like I'm sorry the people
don't hate you because you've got hidden
trees people hate you because you're
repellent yes and I just think that
people would be happier if if that was
something that was said more often my
point being I can see what you mean
there are certain
um uh rhythms and and trends that occur
and people inject and that's not for me
to say that you know every single person
is as bad as Brian like Brian is about
as no 100th percentile as you can get
with regards to this but
some people feel compelled to put
themselves into a movement and their
obsessive dedicated individuals and that
shows up throughout their entire career
of whatever it is that they do another
good example would be Michael Saylor who
I encountered through crypto you might
have heard of you know he's now got
laser eyes on Twitter and he's a he's a
crypto Guru and you go back a little bit
into his history and he's best known for
having lost six billion dollars in a
single day during the.com crash
six and I had to go like check is that a
typo do you mean six million and it was
like no no he was worth allegedly 10
billion and they got by the end of the
day is worth 3.9 billion and I just
think in my big list of people I would
take Financial advice for I probably all
the people who haven't lost six billion
dollars in a single day would be higher
on the list than Michael Saylor but but
that's but that's no bar like that's one
of the things I find really interesting
about that space is there's almost a
kind of idea that if you're flawed it's
more authentic you know so you get these
dating gurus who don't find love
themselves you get these productivity
gurus who are working themselves into
the ground and and like we don't want to
hear necessarily from people who have
got it all figured out we find that kind
of annoying you want to hear from
somebody who's struggling like you are
hmm
that's interesting I based on my
experience I would say the people that
seem to be the most Flawless that are
viewed By Their audience
now as long as they're Flawless now
that's fine if they're flawed now
they're going to get called out because
there is an incentive amongst the
audience for them to continually pick
holes right Derek from more plates more
dates recently released this big
documentary about the liver King I had
him on he made it with my housemate Zach
they're both out in Sacramento at the
moment recording blah blah blah
Derek did a training Vlog with one of my
friends Derek knows more about hormones
and trt and supplements and all of that
stuff than pretty much anybody else on
the planet right
someone saw him doing a training Vlog
and decided to break down his training
style and lambast him for the fact that
he doesn't know how to train why because
he is somebody that has sort of this
purer purest white snow unfettered uh
reputation when it comes to certain
domains and as soon as there's the
opportunity for someone to pick a hole
in it they've been able to do it because
they've said that he doesn't know what
he's doing when it comes to training my
point being that when I think about the
productivity worlds right which is a big
part of my history and also there wasn't
a single person on the episode he did on
productivity that I haven't had on this
podcast not a single person wasn't so
but all of those people because they're
all very productive they do a lot of
podcasts they do they put themselves out
there that's correct but if you were to
look at Ali abdal Ali very rarely opens
up about his own current vulnerabilities
when it comes to productivity like yeah
he'll have problems but his problems
will be significantly better dealt with
than yours are because he's just a
superior productivity guy
um I don't think people would have
followed him had he have had right now
the issues someone that's got a story a
backstory story
in my opinion people don't want to
follow gurus that right now are
struggling through things they like the
idea of a narrative because it creates
that I was where you are you can be
where I am
um but I'm not convinced that it would
be like I'm watching you
fail forward right now because why am I
listening to you why wouldn't I just
listen to someone who's more perfect
even if it's untruthful that's
interesting so I wonder with the liver
King you know and this idea that oh I
can get all these gains by just eating
my raw organs oh no actually it was
human growth hormone do you think that
will affect his sales of his goat organ
pills or his bull organ pills or
whatever he's saying like that's the
thing it ought to my mind to be a huge
blow to his credibility and I'm just not
sure that it will one of the problems
you have is he's so successful and has
so much momentum at the moment and it
was already primed the Paleo movement
and the ancestral Health movement was
already rattling along so
how do you slow that down I I even if
you were to chop his growth in half
let's say that all of the damage that's
been done from you know Rogan me Zach
and Derek over the weekend let's say
that that chops his growth in half he's
still growing more than almost every
other business on the planet and now
he's doing another podcast tour where
he's apologizing for everything he was
on Andrew Schultz yesterday they had to
Febreze the couch that I sat on
yesterday to get rid of the smell of the
liver King so that I could sit down in a
room that didn't honk like organ Meats
what does the liver King smell like does
he smell it
Febreze as far as I'm aware but um they
did have to get the air conditioner out
to to do that
yeah I I don't think it's going to slow
down um but I mean he's he's a another
guy he's seen an opportunity to inject
himself in there's heavy Financial
opportunity here
why not have the answers his apology
video was incredible because it was one
of those bits remember that bit in um
blackout Goes Forth when they he's doing
the summing up speech when blackout is
on trial sorry you're probably too young
to remember it ends with like he is
guilty and then he doesn't turn over the
page and then the other page is guilty
only of caring too much and that was how
I felt like his apology video was right
it's like I yes I am guilty only of
caring too much about young men I just
wanted to be perfect for you and that's
why I had to dope myself to prevent male
suicide take some straw and Decker that
was his solution for it so okay what is
the need
that gurus are tapping into like is
there a other individual or common
Trends in the need that gurus tap into
I think part of it is the desire for
reassurance that everything 's going to
be okay so the last episode is about
looking into the future and if you think
about all the different roles we have in
the
um in our culture about people who look
into the future it's everything from the
super kind of scientific like super
forecasters through meteorologists
through Trend forecasters in fashion all
the way out to tarot and fortune telling
and astrology and all of it's about the
idea that you just want somebody to kind
of listen to your problems and tell you
it'll be okay or like give you some idea
of control and wanting to get some kind
of a grip over a world that can feel
very scary and this is part of my thesis
about it is that you know we're seeing a
decline of people identifying as
religious huge decline in the UK in the
last census
um and you know you don't go to your
priest for advice like you probably
would have done in 1850 so who do you go
to
so it's certainty in an uncertain world
yeah I think that's definitely part of
it
a really interesting
and the reasons they flourish is because
the
idea of how you date somebody has
changed like what people want from a
relationship what they expect from a
relationship has really changed and it's
hard not to see quite a lot of that
stuff as a backlash to feminism right
the idea that what do women want in a
relationship do they actually really
want all this Independence or is it in
some ways making them unhappy that's the
message that you get from a lot of those
manosphere dating gurus yeah I mean
that's an entire rabbit hole that I've
spent an awful lot of this year thinking
about you know yeah
how challenging is it for women who've
only recently just been given parity in
education and employment to find out
that most of their relationship outcomes
are negatively correlated with leaning
into that education and employment women
as they earn more and become better
educated reduce the potential dating
pool of men that they're going to
fundamentally be attracted to on average
women want to date men that are better
educated and better employed than they
are so it's the tall girl problem right
if you're a six foot two girl you're
stuck only dating professional athletes
really if you want to date a man that is
taller than you on average which is what
women seem to want to do and that's like
hard that's harsh on the guys that feel
like they're being left behind it's
harsh on this group of women who finally
just about achieved Independence and
like congratulations like go and go and
finally be the person that you wanted to
be without the restrictions of whatever
predisposition people were saying that
you had to have
but now you're stuck sort of fighting
for this group of Turbo Chads at the top
that are going to maybe
um a wealth of options doesn't encourage
them to behave in an appropriate manner
right so you have sort of heartbroken
and wistful women you have lonely and
sort of Forgotten men and then you have
these guys at the time I don't think
it's particularly good for them either
although maybe in the moment it's
probably not existentially for their
soul in the long term
um so yeah that's a that's a fascinating
question but
when you do not have answers you need to
look to somebody that's got certainty
and one of the ways that I've been able
to identify I think some of the more
guru-esque figures uh people who
weaponize in group and out group
dynamics yeah people who speak with
absolute certainty and very rarely use
caveats if you have somebody that has
both of those things that for me is a
huge huge red light and that is Brian
Rose from London rail this is the way
that the world is it's them that are
trying to shut us down they are the ones
that are trying to stop this we are
together in a movement it's like you
don't care about us you don't care about
any us you're trying to identify the
most easy them that you can because
binding people together over the mutual
hatred of an out group is significantly
easier than binding them together over
the mutual love of an in-group oh yeah
no I completely buy that and actually
our mutual friend Chris Kavanaugh of um
decoding the gurus whose podcast you
went on as a writer reply you know he
and Matt Brown have this very good Guru
amateur which I only discovered after
I'd pitched this series so I'm very glad
about it because I really would feel
like I would have wholesomly ripped it
off otherwise but the idea of these kind
of big pseudo-profound ideas of the kind
of conspiracy thinking like and of the
kind of financial milking you know to me
that's a sign of a bad Guru so I think
you're right what you said earlier on
about the fact that some people are
genuinely motivated because they want to
help other people there are good gurus
right this is there are good priests
rabbis imams but those positions of
authority carry innate dangers to them
and one of them is absolutely the idea
that you have to create a kind of shared
enemy and the really interesting thing
about that is to talk about the IDW
you know I I was thinking about this
quite a lot because as you may have
known I've had a few cancellation
brushes myself and it does it is a quite
a powerful experience it makes you feel
quite sympathetic to people who've been
in the other situation and I think if
you're going to talk about anything that
created the IDW it was the idea that
they'd all got a shared enemy and the
quote-unquote woke that was a more
powerful thing you know uniting people
with very very disparate political
opinions but they could all agree that
journalists from The New York Times in
slate and Vox were very annoying and
that's basically what banned them all
together what is your postmortem on the
IDW
I think it's a real shame because I do
think it did Identify some things that
were important I I definitely do feel
that American journalism in particular
became very polarized and there wasn't a
big middle you know one of the things I
like about living in Britain and having
the BBC you know I go on question time
and I have to sit next to Nigel farage
and the leftmost wing of the labor party
and to complete other you know someone
from the SMP someone from like whatever
it might be people you have to be in the
same space as having those conversations
together and that just doesn't happen in
American journalism you don't get
somebody who's Fox and somebody's MSNBC
forced to share a space very often
um so I like the fact that the IDW was
pointing out the fact that actually
there were lots of things that liberal
institutions liberal media institutions
were missing and they needed to be a bit
more open-minded about that that said I
do think a lot of them were either
straightforward conservatives who
therefore didn't really they weren't
really heterodox they were just
conservative someone like Ben Shapiro
has a pretty consistent conservative
Outlook and there were some people in
there who had some personality issues
that's why I say that's a kind way of
saying it that you know that some of
their their fighting in combative Spirit
actually kind of came from a kind of
restlessness within them rather than
maybe necessarily being such an
intellectual idea
one of the problems that you definitely
have is when
somebody gets a significant amount of
clout for being good in one particular
domain or having a take which seems to
be particularly accurate it's very easy
to get out over your skis and to then
start commenting on stuff that you don't
I mean this story from Douglas Murray
who is a really good friend of mine and
he said someone asked him somebody asked
him something something to do with covid
uh this is a year ago let's say and uh
Douglas said I'm going to do something
which is very rare in the modern world
which is not comment on something which
I know nothing about you're like there
we are like
knowing or at least having the
inclination that you have boundaries to
your competence is something that is
very important and I think that you can
end up in a situation where you
you start commenting on stuff that you
shouldn't do
also that being said
I would agree I think that the IDW was a
much needed
uh like vector of splintering somehow
like it sort of injected itself and sure
enough people made funny memes about it
and there's like articles and all the
rest of it but it managed to inject
itself and and create a breakpoint where
people even now know what they mean by
the intellectual dark web like you know
the dynamic that you were referring to
and even if it's not something which had
the legs to maintain its longevity
longer term perhaps it was an important
sort of uh like breaker switch or
something that just kind of made people
stumble over a little bit and go
actually yeah maybe we do need to be to
see that there is a different way that
things could be or something like that
it's funny you mentioned Douglas Murray
because I have this weird having been
around in journalism now for so long I
have I've all these people's little
Hinterland stick in my mind so I
remember being an undergraduate at
Oxford when in Douglas Murray's a couple
of years older than me he was doing I
think his PhD on Bose you know low down
for Douglas Oscar Wilde's lover and I'm
always so slightly wondered how did you
go from doing a lovely Victorian gay PhD
into being like Douglas Murray of today
it's very exciting to me it's like the
same way that I remember when Miley
Annapolis was a tech blogger at the
Telegraph and then you kind of watch his
Evolution I show you all these other
things I'm not sure I'm not convinced
that Douglas's trajectory and Milos has
been quite as extreme I think no no one
as well as an extreme she is Milo I just
I'm always kind of fascinated by you
know I think I've had a very boring and
Bland career but just the fact that
people just take these weird
intellectual diversions is fascinating
to me like that's the opportunities the
internet gives you would you not say so
Douglas is The Madness of crowds oh lot
of that was about the collapse of grand
narratives that people no longer had the
existing institutions and understanding
of traditional wisdom that they would
have relied on previously heavily coming
in from religion
is that not pretty much the same Dynamic
that you're describing here that it's it
would be maybe more anthropological or
ancestral wisdom but he's talking about
people don't know what to do and in his
view they were turning to a church of
social justice as a solution to their
problems
by that as a thesis I do think that
there are comfort and security in
knowing who your tribe is and and
feeling that people have kind of got
your back
um and you can either get that through
explicitly religious settings or you can
get it from social groups so
um I haven't read Douglas's uh book but
I understand people have found I said
sold very well which I respect and that
people have found lots of interesting
stuff in it and I wouldn't be surprised
if there were parts of it I violently
disagree with and parts of it which I
hardly agree with
foreign
is it not given the fact that there is
such a lack of faith in institutions
especially when it comes to kind of
understanding the world around you at
the moment uh well first off where do
you think that's come from like why is
it that there's such a lack of of faith
in them
I think a lot of this is to do the
democratizing power of the internet and
that again it's on those double-edged
swords right it's not a completely bad
thing that now anybody can set
themselves up as a podcast you know what
is the version of you 20 years ago can
you have this career or do you have to
go through a much more formal process of
going and working on like a local paper
and then hoping that you'll get to go to
Fleet Street because you've joined the
right Union right it doesn't there is a
good side to that and the fact that it
has allowed far more voices to be heard
but some percentage of those voices are
unfortunately going to be bad voices and
I think that's the bit we haven't really
got to is working out that the fact that
gatekeeping is not completely dirty
worked but there was probably far too
much gatekeeping in the media 20 30
years ago and we we still haven't found
the kind of right balance in that to my
mind so given the fact that there is a
lack of
appropriate faith and I think it's well
Justified I mean if if anybody wanted a
nail in the coffin of faith in the
institutions the last three years would
have managed to do it with politicians
and media types just putting their foot
in their mouth and face planting on it
just permanently rolling back previously
stated absolutes and so on and so forth
why not have people come through someone
needs to come through the alternative is
for people to just be bereft out at Sea
with no idea what to do is it better to
have some advice that's hit and miss or
is it better to have no advice at all
all right but you've got to have a
self-correcting mechanism and the great
joy of Science and what the Scientific
Revolution gave us was an idea that you
were engaged in a collective struggle
towards the truth and you would get
things wrong along the way but you would
be part of a community of scientists who
would review your work and you know they
would pick you up when you went wrong
and the great Max Planck saying you know
science advances one funeral at a time
was a recognition of the fact that there
was an unfortunate level of consensus
that often meant that you know it was
about people's personalities rather than
how well they had interpreted stuff but
the idea was that science did still
progress and the same thing happens in
an institution you know I work in the
Atlantic in America magazine and when I
write a print piece for them it goes
through extensive fact Checkers you know
they will go back and ask me for sources
they will go you know they will
sometimes re-interview people to check
that I've got things right you know
there is a level of that and in the same
way if I got something horribly wrong
there would be an open transparent
process of Corrections and that's the
ideal right sometimes that doesn't work
the ideal is not that you never get
anything wrong the idea is you do
everything you can to stop yourself
getting things wrong and when you do get
things wrong you correct them and you're
transparent about it and that's what
kind of annoys me I guess about some of
the people who spend all their time
slating the mainstream media you know I
say this is a fully paid up MSM shell
but you know is that do they have
similar levels of rigor and fact
checking and then owning up and pressing
out when they get wrong or do they just
kind of go oh well I mean I was I was
right spiritually or they would say that
wouldn't they how is it the case if
that's the sort of process that you go
through at the Atlantic that articles
that come out in the guardian and the
New York Times managed to get published
I see almost on what seems to be a very
regular basis some
insane titled thing talking about how
the calories on the back of a bar of
chocolate and how the homophobic or
whatever it is that the guardian's
putting out like
it seems it seems to me that a lot of
the takes that they go through don't
have that degree of rigor so it doesn't
seem like mainstream media is protected
by the uh rules and procedures
necessarily
that's funny you would pick two
left-wing examples because I would
actually say that's a bigger problem on
the right the problem of disinformation
I think if you um as I did recently I
came back from America I spent some time
in Florida watching you know just the
average evening viewing of Fox News
right that is an incredibly narrative
driven
um product and manages to create these
whole ideas out of kind of whole cloth
which are really interesting that people
just kind of become fixated on this very
narrow idea that everyone should be
talking about without any kind of
underlying idea what what they actually
I mean I'm thinking of and to buy this
laptop I'm also thinking of critical
race there I'm also thinking of the
short-lived Crusade against ESG and
pensions but you know they are kind of
narrative machines as much as their
deliveries of fact so I don't think it's
a unique problem on the left at all and
I think what you're probably identifying
is opinion pieces rather than straight
news reporting that's people having
calories are homophobic is a bad opinion
not necessarily bad facts is it I mean
our calories are my favorites I don't
know it's both but yeah I mean I think
that what that shows is the
Echo chamber of whatever the algorithm
likes to serve me is bringing up the
most egregious transgressions that it
sees from the left that it'll it'll pop
up Libs of tick tock and it'll pop up
whatever else
um but I imagine that there must be a
like rights of tick tock as well there
must be an equivalent account for the
transgressions that come from the other
side of the fence
yeah that's interesting I mean there are
media monitoring Services you know
there's medium matters and stuff like
that I can't think of anyone that does
picks out random individuals like the
thing that's the thing is I have
consumed Libs of tick tock I have
laughed at at mad Americans
um saying stupid things about gender we
all have uh you know it's okay but I I
can't think of a right-wing version of
that that does it where it picks out
individual right with people I guess
maybe actually in their Heyday things
like The Daily Show and The Colbert
Report did that they used to go and
interview some Trump supporters and they
would set them up to make them look
silly and that was a kind of Lo-Fi low
churn version of what Libs of tick tock
did now and actually probably we should
be similarly uncomfortable about that
and I again probably laughed at all of
that in the 2000s in a way that probably
made me feel quite uncomfortable now
that you're just picking individual
Normie people and holding them up as as
idiots to be kind of mocked by the crowd
in your opinion then is the mainstream
media is still putting out on average
the best content it's putting out better
more accurate content than individual
creators
I mean it depends what you're talking
about really I follow an enormous number
of sub stacks and one of the reasons I
really like doing that is I want to hear
from the world nerdy expert in a
particular topic about this you know my
friend John Ellis has got one where he
writes about the transport policy and
trains and just this you know in a level
of detail you were simply not going to
get in in the mainstream media because
it's only interesting to a certain
number of people and that has been
really positive because
as a journalist anywhere really even if
you're a specialist because you are to
some extent a generalist you have to
make yourself an expert on things very
quickly I mean I guess it speaks to a
bit like what you do right you you have
to interview an enormous number of
people and you have to make your you
have to master the subjects very quickly
and that's a tough thing to do and it's
a tough thing to get right and didn't
know what the probing questions are to
ask so there is that problem and I do
think individual creators can sometimes
do better at that stuff the really
hardcore scrutiny but there is a huge
problem and you definitely saw this with
the IDW about who you know you're
becoming essentially a version of
regulatory capture being captured by
your audience where they only want one
type of content and also becoming too
chummy with your subjects you know one
of the things that's interesting to me
is that you know having done political
journalism for so long is I'm quite
critical of the lobby system the Press
Corps in the US you know the idea is
there's great journalists working there
but you're spending all day and night
with politicians they're your sources
you can't burn them or screw them over
and that means you can't do very you
know you would weigh up whether or not
it's worth burning a relationship for to
do a story and and you have to in order
to be able to do that you also have to
have a paper that backs you
um and we'll deal with that you know the
relationship with the Trump White House
or wherever it is being in flames and
also you know the advertisers aren't
going to Desert you and I think that you
know the thing is about in an
institution like journalism is only
really a collection of individuals right
I can't take on Elon Musk I can't stand
up to Elon Musk and scrutinize his
practices as me what I can do is Chip in
My 20 a year towards a mainstream
newspaper that can actually do that and
can report and send writers to do it and
I think it you know it's very
fashionable to criticize the mainstream
media and rightly so I've got my own
many criticisms about working within it
but there's an enormous amount of just
shoe leather very boring reporting you
know who's the person who goes to the
court case and sits through it all the
way through you know who is the person
who sits through the hours of Senate
testimony and listens to all that stuff
you know there are lots of the problem
is that we We complain about the high
profile annoying journalists and the
kind of Bedrock of people who
go and find things out day in and day
out we just actually don't talk about we
just all rely on them to have to kind of
discover the facts on which the rest of
us can all then have an argument is it
not the case was that stirring were you
not stirred by that Chris are you not
you know do you not now concede that
actually the mainstream meet the hated
mainstream media might occasionally do
some good well it depends on whether you
uh what it is that you're reading and
what you're exposed to right because the
stuff that most people will see will be
the egregious examples it'll be the
Taylor Lorenz crying for the 15th time
about whatever it is that she's recently
done and
I realized a little while ago that
there's always been a dynamic where
individual groups are categorized by the
most extreme members that are within it
right so previously it would have been
that um all Muslims are Isis members
right you know that that's like a pretty
old Trope then it would be
um to do with everybody that's on the
left is part of this sort of blue haired
sjw thing or anybody that's on the right
is a bigoted homophobic racist blah blah
blah I think that there's an equivalent
Dynamic going on within individuals so
you might have heard of something called
the peak end rule
so Peak Andrew was found by Daniel
Kahneman and what it suggests is that
when you remember an event you remember
the most extreme or the most intense
part and you also remember the end so
you remember the peak you remember the
end and you did this this is why if you
give someone a colonoscopy you should
just leave it and not wiggle it about a
bit yes correct that's a bit that really
stuck in my mind yeah sure it did and so
what I've come to believe is that there
is an equivalent rule for public figures
in the world called the peak hate rule
so people are remembered by their worst
transgression and by their most recent
transgression right so uh when thinking
about Jordan Peterson if you're a Critic
of his you will see him as a transphobe
that didn't call students by their
preferred pronouns and someone that
criticizes Sports Illustrated girls on
the internet if you think about Hassan
Pika you will think about a person who
said America deserves 911 and someone
who claims to be a socialist but now
lives in a five million dollar mansion
in wherever the [ __ ] it is that he lives
right you have the worst transgression
and you have their most recent
transgression that's what people are
seen as that's how much of the public
views in my opinion
big names that they see that exist like
out there that create stuff and after a
while people no longer actually are seen
as people like people don't see the
normal person doesn't see Joe Rogan as a
person they see him as an amalgamation
of ideas he's like a representation of
an ideology fused into human form it
just happens to be that the human was
there before and has always gone through
but that's why I think some of the
dehumanizing language that gets used
because it doesn't feel like you're
criticizing a person it feels like it's
some not like a deity but like like a
symbol almost that's what you're going
for and that's where I think the peak
hate rule uh sort of ties in a little
bit as well that's really interesting I
mean I have a kind of weird perspective
on this because I have one group of
people on the internet who hate me for
being
um you know a a transfer but another
group of people who hate me for being a
kind of work careerist and you're like
okay but I can't I can't judge this you
you I think all of you should get
together and fight it out given that
you've got completely Divergent things
that you hate me for and come up to some
sort of synthesis or resolution of this
but yeah it's a fundamentally
dehumanizing experience but I also think
that you also cast people as the thing
that you find easiest to argue against
um so the Atlantic has a number of great
rules that they tell you when you join
one of which is something like don't be
a dick I mean I think they phrase it
slightly more than that but it's like we
don't care how good your copy is you
still got to be pleasant to your
co-workers which again is something that
I think more people could benefit from
being told but the other one is you have
to argue with the best version of your
opponent's argument because what you're
talking then about is a is a thing
called nut picking like cherry picking
but for for the nuts and it's really
easy to do that and really lazy to do
that in Internet arguments go and find
some one saying something stupid and
argue with them and I have that
experience sometimes when I write a
piece and people don't argue with the I
mean this is very basic stuff but people
don't argue with the piece that you've
actually written they argue that the
piece that they've been waiting for
someone to write so that they can have a
go at that piece and make themselves
look good
so I wrote a piece about Elon Musk a
couple of weeks ago which I said you
know a number of things about how I
think he's very
writing Twitter in a very Celtic way and
I can see why no one would want to live
there but I was trying to explain his
appeal and why if you look at any of his
mad Dragon tweets they've all got a
hundred thousand likes on them I was
going like he is playing the heel he
like you know he likes being the the
villain and his whole stick is do you
want to have Mark Zuckerberg pretending
to care about healing the world or Sam
bankman freed you know saying I've got
to earn all this money because I need to
give it away or do you just want to have
me going I'm rich I mean I must I do
what I want like Cartman from South Park
and actually a lot of people find that
much more honest they assume that all
rich people are awful and at least
you're telling the truth about it and
people did not like that they were like
do you like the taste of licking elon's
boot you know Lackey and I was like this
piece is really critical of him but I'm
just saying that people do like him and
that is an observable fact in the world
but they wanted to argue with the pro
Elon piece right so they just decided
that that's the piece I'd written and
it's the great tragedy of social media
is that you become what people need you
to be to make them to to be themselves
what they want to present to the world
we saw this the most easy example that I
saw of what you're describing also the
PK rule was just before Sam Harris left
Twitter every single tweet that he put
up was replied to by hundreds of people
with the same quote of I wouldn't care
if Hunter Biden had dead children in his
basement that laptop story still
shouldn't have been like stopped or
whatever it was that that he said and
I'm like well like I get it but he
wasn't tweeting about that and bringing
that up kind of just seems a little bit
pointless but for some people like
that's the most recent great
transgression that he did so therefore
that's how we're going to categorize
that
um
you also looked at someone that drank
their own urine
why
did you look at them and why were they
drinking oh right why do they drink
they're in urine yeah there was a there
was a conversation where I went you know
I love the BBC but I do not love the BBC
enough to drink my own urine I'm just
gonna put that out there now don't ask
me I will not do I will do anything for
love but I will not do that
um is your own sweet Canadian guy who
was a contestant on Canadian Idol called
um will blunderfield
lovely just got off the phone with him
and I just thought what a sweet young
man but drinks his own piss and not just
his own piece as it turns out there's a
whole video where he's like and it's got
a little bit of pre-cum in it and we had
a long discussion about whether or not
it was just simply too unpleasant a
phrase to be airing on Radio 4 when
people might be having you know their
breakfast
um we decided we're going to keep it in
uh anyway because you know that's that's
real life but um yeah that is drinking
your own urine is one of these strangely
recurrent practices so it's still used
in traditional medicine in sub-Saharan
Africa and places like that but it has
been something that hippies have kind of
done frequently and I just do not
understand it like I If there is any
signal that your body is giving to you
in regards to urine it's like I want
this out of me this is this is like this
is leaving the body now not like it
needs to come back in but it's something
you find quite a lot and you know for
him it's part of it's she calls it
shavambu and it's part of his kind of
Wellness practice but the interesting
thing about talking to him was he had
had an eye conditions strabismus where
one of his eyes didn't quite track
properly and had spent most of his
childhood being medicalized and then he
came out as gay and was essentially gay
bashed when he was holding his first
boyfriend's hand and went to a
psychiatrist or therapist to talk about
it and instead of being given talking
therapy really was put on pills with
said you know you want some
antidepressant pills and I understood
from those two experiences why someone
would get to the place where they are
very skeptical of mainstream traditional
medicine why they don't want to be
within what he calls the allopathic
system and so he's become more and more
invested in anti-vac stuff he's one of
the people those people who believe that
if you don't eat certain things then you
don't need to wear sunscreen
um which you know he lives in Vancouver
where it's pretty chilly most of the
time so we may get away with it but I
think if you live in Australia probably
life-threatening kind of level of advice
but I wanted to try and do more than the
standard anti-vaxx thing of saying well
these people are just wrong and kind of
understand psychologically where someone
how someone would get to those opinions
hmm
you know what I mean because if you want
to argue with anti-vex people or try and
convince anti-vax people then there are
a couple of things you need to do and
one of them is be open to the question
of whether or not there are occasional
vaccine injuries which there are right
they're just incredibly rare and much
much rarer than you know and it's much
much more dangerous to get the illness
that you're vaccinating against so on
just a rational risk calculation basis
you just go I would rather take my
chances with the measles vaccine than
take my chances with measles and that's
that's where I come from and all of that
but and I think that's probably a you
know I said that to him essentially and
I think that's an easier thing to say to
people than I kind of no no we all
believe in vaccines a kind of mystical
reverential feeling which I do have
about vaccines I think vaccines are one
of the best things that Humanity's ever
done but I can't expect everybody to
share that feeling whereas I can make a
pragmatic argument based on the on the
studies and what they show
when it comes to health and fitness it
seems like there are a lot of degrees of
freedom despite the fact that everybody
cares about having good health and
eating the right things I had a
dietitian on not long ago a guy called
Max lugavier and asked him
why is it that we understand the speed
of light and yet no one can agree on
whether eating carbs is better or worse
for you than other different types of
macronutrients he's like well it's
because there are so many degrees of
freedom within exercise science and
nutrition science that you can fit these
studies to show basically whatever it is
that you want you can get them to to
become whatever it is that you want to
do and I think that this rolls all the
way through everything to do with health
and fitness everybody wants to be
healthy everybody wants to be in good
condition everybody wants to live a long
life
sometimes you end up drinking your own
piss
my friend Karen and creative Paris wrote
about in her book invisible women that
one of the things these studies won't do
often they will often exclude women from
them if you're looking at any kind of
medical study because they'll just say
women's hormonal Cycles are too crazy
they're just injecting all this stuff
into the data we don't wonder so you
will find quite big drug studies that
are only tested on on men because just
adding in female hormones is is just
considered to be like too wacky never
mind the idea that people have different
hormonal profiles as they go through age
for example and like what might be an
appropriate dose for a 20-something man
and a 70 year old man might be very
different we just don't know about that
internal body chemistry but yeah I know
what you mean you have there has to be a
certain level of humility about things
that are related to health because
Health advice does change and is fluid
and is always this is the best that we
know right now not the kind of final
finished tablet of stone being handed
down well when you think about something
which is even more arbitrary in terms of
your life well-being I suppose product
activity like I say a world that I used
to come from one that spent a lot of
time in very good friends with Ali
abdall who spent a good bit of time
speaking to on the show and yet that is
I would guess probably the largest
personal development subsection on
YouTube and also probably in non-fiction
too it'll be
that and spirituality I would guess
would probably be the two when it comes
to books uh and people are obsessive
about that people need a guru behind
that because if I can fit more into my
life then it's kind of the same as me
extending the amount of time that I'm
alive it's a denial of death
yeah I really like the productivity
gurus they were my um they're the most
wholesome Bunch shall we say like I
liked lots of people but they were the
ones I felt least you know the least
guilty about liking because they are
just genuinely mostly very hard-working
people who want to try and help other
people achieve their goals but even then
like you say I did feel there was a
certain downside to it which is that
lots of people feel that they're lacking
something you know that they're always I
think Oliver Bertman put it about the
idea that people feel like they wake up
in the morning with a debt you know
they're already behind and they spend
the whole day kind of catching up and
they never just think that what they've
got is enough they always feel that
they're failing and that was definitely
something that spoke to me I'm a
terrible workaholic I actually I went to
a therapist about four years ago and my
main thing that I wanted to talk about
was like how can I say no please teach
me how to say no to work
um because I will always feel like oh
they'll never ask me again or I should
feel so flattered to be asked or you
know what if this opportunity doesn't
come up again
and you have to you know then you get
the kind of classic Warren Buffett
advice which is most people are very
successful saying no to most things and
you think Warren Buffett how do you do
it tell me maybe I need to get Warren
Buffett round to turn down you know
minor appearances on the BBC for me like
I just can't do it I I don't have the
self-control or the stamina for it I
think Oliver's approach in 4 000 weeks
is the best one that I found it's like
look you're not going to be able to do
all of this stuff prepare in advance
what you're going to suck at pick a
small domain of things that you want to
be good at and then just leave the rest
so if the productivity people were the
ones that you enjoyed loving the most
who were the ones that you hated loving
the most
was this someone that you found in
affinity for and you felt guilty about
it
well I say say I felt I felt very bad
about the fact that I fundamentally
disagree with Will on you know the
merits of drinking your own pace but I
nonetheless got on with him and I didn't
you know it's a difficult line to walk
when you're presenting someone with
extreme views like that I went and
looked up the scientific litter and
drinking your own urine listen it kind
of amused me there's not really that
much except that when it's used in
traditional medicine there is a worry
that you will pass on drug resistant
bacteria from one person's urine to
another and he went very sweetly oh I
wouldn't drink someone else's like oh no
that's that's the act of a Madman
um which was really funny because it
just proves that everybody's got their
own line for what they consider to be
kooky and some people's line is further
out there than mine but it's you know
it's still there
so I did like them um I found the pickup
artist really difficult to deal with
because having written about feminism
for so long I have
you know I know what those communities
can be like
um and how
deliberately cruel they can be to people
that they feel are against them I think
one of the kind of most dangerous things
in life is feeling that you can be
horrible to other people because you've
got a grievance and that justifies it if
you see what I mean
oh that women have completely taken over
you know that actually it's much harder
to be a man now
um that women are withholding sex from
men that they hold all the cards in
relationships that they routinely make
false rape accusations you know those
kind of things that you see over and
over and my experience of you know
having
a lightly encountered those communities
before is that they will just pick over
the fact that they'll say you know well
of course you know like all the things
they say about me like you know I
haven't got any kids so obviously I'm
Gonna Die Alone
um all you know just feel really ugly or
whatever it is and probably when I was
younger that kind of bothered me more I
think maybe now I just don't care
anymore but they're you know that they
were a community that seemed absolutely
Delight in trashing anybody who crossed
them and I could see where it came from
I could see that it came from this
feeling it was about leveling the
playing field about settling a score
making redress but I think that's always
such an incredibly dangerous thing to
kind of tell yourself give yourself
moral license that you know I'm allowed
to do this because I'm in the right I
don't have to obey the normal rules
because I'm my cause is Justified that
rarely leads to good places in my view
um yeah I got a
sometimes there'll be comments on the
channel talking about
um how this person or this researcher or
this analyst doesn't agree with the
existing sacred cows that the red pill
or the manosphere or the whatever
Community agrees with and every single
time that I see that it seems to me to
be a pretty good sign because I'm like
the further that I continue to reinforce
the fact that this is not a channel for
people that want manosphere content this
is not a channel for people that want
red pill content this is not a channel
for people that want to create them and
US tribal
adversarial relationships between men
and women
every single person that I speak to sees
the fundamental relationship between men
and women as one that is collaborative
not competitive and that is
so hard to find on the internet like
even even when it comes from uh like L
and Cosmopolitan uh how to sleep with
him and not catch feels you know how to
get over how to get your boyfriend like
back by Sleeping with his best friend
like these are articles non-ironic
articles that go out in
commercial magazines right this isn't
some [ __ ] R female dating strategy
pink pill
depths of the internet stuff this is buy
it on a magazine shelf stuff like that's
really really terrible like if you want
to point a finger at toxic femininity
which sometimes is like what where's
where's the toxic feminine it's like
it's right [ __ ] there like that's one
of the instances
I mean I think most toxic feminine is
actually directed if you want to concede
that that's a concept I mean I would I'm
pretty relaxing David to say toxic
masculinity or talks femininity because
I think a lot of people just instantly
switch off at that point but I think if
there is such a thing as toxic
femininity it's probably women directing
it other women
um largely but I know what you mean like
having written a book about feminism I
thought a lot about how to make a
message that a book even a man could
enjoy but you know what I mean like and
I had a a male friend of mine read the
draft and I talked it through them and
you kind of said in a couple of places
you know like yeah have you thought
about it from our point of view and you
know there was a time in Internet
feminism where that would have been
something that people would have scoffed
at you know there was a kind of German
sort of drinking male tears era of
Internet feminism no it is very
ostentatiously like someone got a
hashtag trending once it was like kill
all white men or something like that and
then they had to explain that right but
then there was this whole people went
that's very offensive and they went no
no it's actually obviously it would be
offensive the other way around but it's
okay because it's a punch she satire on
power relations and you're like oh God
are you all of you 12 don't do that but
you know and I did have a and the
conclusion that okay eventually came to
in difficult women is that you have to
have a kind of policy-based idea of
feminism right here are the things that
we want and like you could agree with me
or not so if I say to you look you know
I think it's mad that the US doesn't
have any federally mandated maternity
leave women have to Cobble together bits
of their holiday and unpaid time off I'm
not requiring you to agree with me that
women are in some way better than men or
like everyone has to have their unique
generals whatever it is it's just a
thing that you can agree with or not on
a policy level and that fundamentally to
me is where feminism can go in a way
that builds coalitions rather than being
about some of those dry arguments about
who's more of a [ __ ] than the other
gender right yes well I mean that goes
back to what I said before about men and
women fundamentally being collaborative
rather than competitive because
intra-sexual competition is way way way
bigger than intersexual competition
right women compete with women mostly
and men compete with men mostly
ancestrally that seems to be the case
and it looks the same way now on average
it's have you seen the stats around uh
most pro-life votes come from women
rather than men
yeah I don't think that there's a
massive percentage difference but it
makes sense to me that there are women
who are very invested in the idea of
themselves as mothers and
um and having a maternal caring role and
taking care of babies and and therefore
they see abortion through that prism
they don't see it through the prism of
personal Independence and freedom and
bodily autonomy so yeah I know what you
mean it's really interesting when you do
those kind of slice and dice like you
just you get it a lot in um arguments
over things like sex work oh we'll just
listen to Listen to women listen to sex
Works listen to whatever the group is
and actually in the case of people who
are working currently in the sex
industry they're going to by definition
have one set of views on it right you're
not going to find a lot of radical
feminist abolitionists working in the
sex industry for very good reasons and
so those appeals to Identity can often
be incredibly
um reductive really as if we don't live
in a society and only one group of
people get to have opinions on the
things that they do you know we don't
only ask billionaires about what tax lip
rates billionaires would pay oh yeah
okay that seems like a really good idea
I can imagine probably what that answer
is going to be thanks what did you learn
from the crypto gurus the crypto Bros
um so one of them I interviewed I don't
know if you know him is Peter McCormack
who bought real Bedford FC
really interesting fun guy great to get
along with he grew up in Bedford
um which for American listeners is like
what's what's the kind of very boring
American town I'm not just not sure
there is a anywhere in like anywhere in
like India Westchester it's about
Westchester like it's outside London but
it's not super um fun but it's a really
lovely place to live but anyway he um he
made all this money through crypto and
his podcast and then he bought real
Bedford FC
um and he now has like a non little
non-league team that is sponsored by
some of these crypto exchanges and gets
fans from around the world and you know
I it's a really quite a sweet and
heartwarming story that he wanted to
take his internet gains and put them
back into an area that he felt needed
more opportunities for young people so I
really liked him on that the funny thing
about Peter is that he thinks that
almost all crypto is [ __ ] and full
of scam artists he only believes in
Bitcoin and I said to him this is really
funny right he's a Bitcoin he's a
Bitcoin Maxi and I said this is really
funny to me because this is like how I
feel as an atheist talking to people who
believe in God you know this the famous
Ricky's of a race quote about that you
think 99 of God it's a [ __ ] I just
think one more is [ __ ] and that's
how you know I I feel a bit about crypto
I I haven't ever seen the proposition
beyond the fact that technology is
really interesting
um I haven't really seen how you can
create ass you know the value of the
asset Beyond more people buying into a
limited resource and so he was a really
fun and challenging conversation because
he was like you're gonna come back in 10
years time and you're going to admit
that I'm right because places in the
developing world that don't have access
to mainstream Financial mechanisms by
decentralized Finance they can skip that
whole generation and so yeah we have to
meet up again in 10 years time and find
out if my skepticism was was validated
or not one of the good litmus tests
around crypto has been what happens in a
bear market and what happens in a bull
market if it was that everybody just
cared about being able to give families
in war-torn countries the opportunity to
send money across the border without
government interference you should be
still singing the Praises of the
technology when the price is 15 000 the
same as it was when it was sixty
thousand
why aren't you why aren't everybody on
the internet singing about how brilliant
the new crypto toad pixel nft is what's
because it's not worth as much like
almost everybody that's into crypto you
like it because you're you're able to
make free money overnight that's why you
like it that's fine that's absolutely
fine but don't try and tell me that it's
because you love the opportunity to
repatriate people in developing worlds
from the tyranny of some government that
wants to take the it's it's got nothing
to do with that it's got nothing to do
with that or else you would still be
just as passionate when the market was
[ __ ] is when the market was good and the
market is currently [ __ ] and no one's
talking about it except being critical
uh yeah but it again I think it's a
place where mainstream journalism came
off a lot better than the individuals
right because that's a classic example
of the fact you had people with a direct
financial interest in the sector being
the ones who said Don't listen to the
fud you know you just got a hodl and
like that's because their money directly
depends on people doing those those
things holding on for dear life and
suppressing Their Fear uncertainty and
doubt you know and whereas if you work
on the financial times you are much
Freer to go I've taken a look at this
crypto exchange and they're you know
what's the great thing from the um the
FTX thing where he had a a tab on the
spreadsheet that said poorly hidden Fiat
account and it had eight billion like
the eight billion dollar black hole was
was concealed within it right that's the
kind of thing that you need you know
people on the outside who have no direct
financial interest to turn and go ah
just going to stop you there that that
looks bad that feels bad to me bad
what
what was gurui about the the stuff that
you looked at today with crypto it seems
like he just spoke to a guy that bought
it
a football team I don't know is he
proselytizing is he trying is he part of
a pyramid scheme is what's he trying to
do are there other people to do with
crypto that we're trying to sell it
yeah so Peter Peter is a uh he's an
interesting one because he's a kind of
sort of almost like a self-hating guru
and that he says you know come for the
game stay for the revolution like he
he's invested in people getting into
crypto Because he believes in the power
of the technology
um but that's not where everybody is you
know we spoke to uh Leia heilpern who's
another British crypto Guru she's very
big she got she's a very big libertarian
she actually you're like this she now
lives most of the time in Miami because
she thinks that British men are weak and
effeminate and I said is the girl who
keeps defending Andrew Tate on Fox News
yes yeah so and I said hang on a minute
men in Miami like Miami home of the
famous like incredibly Camp Muscle Beach
of men in tiny shorts who like the
company of other men these are your like
you know this is what the Paradigm of
masculinity is to you and yeah I don't
think we really got very much further
than that but it was just very funny to
me because I think London is full of big
Hench Lads
um and I don't know what your history of
expertise not mine she's just not going
to the right places basically is what I
think
and what did you learn yeah
well she was really interesting because
um
Jewish and and I did say to her like
would you have Kanye on the podcast and
now he's in his full intermitted pump
and she's like yeah I would and I was
like what about an actual Neo-Nazi and
she's like yeah I would and that to me
is a kind of just a completely different
fundamental approach to free speech than
I have which you know there's sort of
much more libertarian ideas and that
carries through into a lot of that
crypto space is very libertarian they
absolutely don't believe in government
intervention they don't you know they're
very hostile to the whole idea of of
government and it's really interesting
talking to people like that because I'm
a kind of Normie Social Democrat you
know I think it's I quite like the idea
that when I phone the fire brigade the
fire brigade turn up like that's fine by
me
um and so it's always really challenging
it's one of the things I really
appreciate about doing this job is
talking to people who have ended up in
very different political positions to me
who are clearly smart and like working
out what it is that got them there and
got me here
foreign
public humiliation bondage thing where
white women were made to be shouted at
around the table but they couldn't cry
bondage but I think you may have just
added that in your own artists whatever
yeah yeah the series isn't out yet I can
imagine what I want right okay well um
so race to dinner was founded by two
women uh an indian-american woman called
Sarah Rao and a black American woman
called Regina Jackson and they for five
thousand dollars um a dinner will get a
woman to invite all her white women
friends and then they will ask them
who's racist and put up the hands of
their racist
well no then you get shouted at because
you should have put your hand up because
everyone's racing it's a Kafka trap it's
Kafka dinner
yeah um but but Sarah will put up our
hands because she says you know as a as
a person of color he's not black she is
institutionally anti-black and the way
that the racial hierarchy works in the
US is that everybody who isn't black
thinks well it could be worse I could be
black that's their premise but the thing
that got me about this is just and I
think maybe part of this has been
British as well I just thought I
wouldn't pay to someone to tell me that
I would pay five grand for somebody to
tell me that I'm racist I'd pay five
grand to tell me that I'm amazing maybe
is there a certificate
credential at the end of it I'm
wondering why you would pay five
thousand dollars to have this I mean is
the food particularly good is the
service nice
no there is not a no there is not a
goodie bag at the end of it like what's
going on as far as I know absolutely
absolute okay so here's the thing that I
think is there is a deep strain of
masochism I think through a lot of women
particularly white liberal middle class
women you know these are the same group
of people who buy women's magazines that
tell you that you're fat and disgusting
and you need to diet
um and the same people who look at Daily
my sidebar of Shame about you know
people who've got cankles and turkey
necks and all the things that kind of
horribly wrong with you you know and I
think a lot back to my formative
experience when I was a teenager I used
to read FHM which kind of dates me
because it hasn't existed for like two
decades now because I found the men's
magazines of the 90s were like you're
amazing like here's how to go out and
score some chicks like here's the where
we went to Vegas in a poker game and
like you know the guy who lost had to
get breast implants a real story I
remember from FHM and the women's
magazines were like here are all the
ways in which you're failing like here's
how to pluck your hair at various bits
of your body so you're not repellent
anymore and I thought I don't this is
not for me like I want I want fun and
adrenaline and racing big cars around
um and I think that
that tendency that sort of
self-legelating tendency has carried on
and I did ask them I said you couldn't
get eight men to sit down
and listen to how they're all racist and
pet and and then pay you like I just
don't believe that that business model
works with men and that that to me is
completely fascinating that there is
some kind of Miss sort of yeah deep
masochistic streak in some kind of white
middle liberal class women where they
want to be told that they're terrible
and sort of luxuriating it did you draw
a line between that and Rob and
D'Angelo's work
yeah so they one of the things I said to
them about you know what a great
business model five grand to make white
women cry you know I've been trying to
do that with my articles for years but
I've never got paid that much for it
um they said we used to you know that's
a racist question you should see how
much Robin D'Angelo gets paid and it's
true she gets paid an enormous amount of
money
um and and and white fragility there is
a chapter called white women's tears
which is all about how you know that it
is emotionally manipulative when white
women are confronted with their racism
that they will burst into tears and
everyone will Comfort them
um and there's this whole slew of books
called things like white feminist or
um brown skin white tears you know that
are all about this premise that white
women are the absolute worst and the
audience for that is white women you
know that's what I just I it so one of
those times where I just think Shades of
Gray without any of the sex right I just
I don't understand I don't fundamentally
understand that mindset either so I was
trying to get into that that mindset too
about a kind of purification rituals
yeah what have you come to believe like
what what's you have written about women
for a long time you have been a woman
for a long time and
you have now considered this new
public flagellation
self-amiliation humiliation thing with a
five grand price tag how does this fit
into the broader Narrative of what you
think it means to be a white
middle-class woman in the modern world
I think it's even more than that I mean
I think about the brilliant um
you survival people by Hillary mantel in
the London review books which is her
review of stay with me on this her
review of books about medieval Saints
may have an evil anorexic Saints and
it's called some girls want out and it's
basically about the fact that all of
these women looked at the kind of
bargain about what it meant to be a
woman in the world and they went no I'm
not doing it I'm going to a nunnery and
I'm starving myself and I'm going to
have these sort of trances that are
caused by hunger and see visions of
Jesus I want I want out and then when I
was growing up lots of girls used to do
self-harm you know you had cutting scars
all down your arms
um and then I wrote a piece last year
about uh white women primarily in
Academia who pretended to be women of
color like the sort of Rachel dollar
kind of feel
which was always really interesting was
that they were women who worked in like
race studies and they decided they
identified so strongly with the idea of
being minorities that they came to
believe that they were minorities
themselves in some way and I talked to
an expert in munchausen's factitious
disorder because I wondered if this was
a kind of social version of that what is
that what's munchausen's I've heard of
it so I don't know what it is so
munchosens is when you keep reporting to
the doctor with injuries that you have
either dreamed up or inflicted on
yourself so classic you know people sort
of drink bleach and then talk about
their stomach ulcers or whatever it is
and munchausen's by proxy is when you
often usually take to child you know you
make them ill deliberately because
people want that patient role they want
that attention they want the sympathy
they get a feeling of validation from
from it
um and I think that there was a kind of
similar thing happening on a social
level with those academics that they
wanted
to be the minority they wanted to be
speak with the authority and truth and
you look through it happens through
every major historical event you know
there are fake Holocaust Survivors there
are fake batter clown survivors they're
a fake 911 survivors some people are
just innately drawn to that idea of you
know spilling their guts and being a
victim in that sense and you know I
talked to an expert on munchausen's and
I said it was really notable to me that
that these are primarily women and he
said well I think you know often men
when they're kind of troubled and
sociopathic they turn it outwards they
go out on the big binge drinking spray
or They smash something up or they drive
the car too fast or whatever it is they
get into fights and women turn it
inwards and women become anorexic women
self-harm I think you can see it related
to the way that teenage girls now often
are reporting with gender dysphoria they
are turning that pain inwards on them on
themselves
um and I do think that's probably
something that is either through
socialization or biology just a
fundamental difference in the way that
kind of those things manifest and they
want to go to these dinners as a another
form of that
yeah it is but it is a bit like
self-harm isn't it it's somebody to tell
you that you're awful with the premise
that then you
you purify yourself at the end which is
something that comes up a lot in
discussions of anorexia right that
people don't want to eat food because
it's sort of dirty and disgusting or
they don't want to have an adult body
because it's dirty and disgusting so
there are I think the same ideas of
Purity perhaps that persist through all
of that
I'm sure men do it too right like I'm
sure that there are men who become a
nurse I mean there are men who become
anorexic or there are men who who juice
because they want to have a you know
they have an idea that their body's
disgusting if it's not got like seven
percent
body fat or whatever it might be yeah I
think that that was it seems like the
liver King says that his sense of
self-esteem contributed to him wanting
to be in in this sort of condition that
he's trained twice a day with these
brain busting workouts for many hours
seven days a week for however many
decades he's been doing it for for
precisely that reason
um it does seem like a phenomenon that
women are more
susceptible to
than guys I mean self-harm rates I think
are higher amongst girls than they are
amongst boys yeah suicide attempts are
higher among women but successful
suicide suicide attempts are higher
among men yeah uh that's so that's I
mean that's a that's a really really
interesting statistic that I still
haven't worked out what to do with that
in my mind you know when
you know your famous conversation with
Jordan Peterson one of the things that
he says back you know however many
percent of suicides are men uh and you
go well
yes
how do we fold into that conversation
that women attempt it more
like what is it what does it mean to say
like how many failed suicide attempts is
worth a successful suicide attempt like
if you try to kill yourself a hundred
times is that the same as one person
that manages to do it once how much of
those can be written off as a cry for
help how much of that is just a literal
lack of ability to use lethal Force like
how many women would have done it had
they have been able to do it how many
like there's so many different filters
and layers that you go through here and
I really don't know how to fold that in
I think about it more frequently than I
probably realize uh that you've got
those two stats that kind of
yeah I know what you mean it's one of
those things that doesn't no and you
can't draft it into any kind of sexual
format because it's not like I don't
think there's anything that we could be
doing differently in gender terms that
would make the men's rates come down
like you know what I mean there's no way
in which I think it's women's fault that
men are killing themselves at that rate
like it's not that the reasons for
suicide are so difficult and complex and
often usually like a whole Welter of
different factors that it resists being
conscripted into any kind of simple
narrative
um but I agree with you like I I I
really wish that we had a better idea
that we actually knew what the
prescription was to lower male suicide
rates like I just think that's the bit
that no one seems to know no one seems
to know it's not like one of those
situations where you know we we know
what the you know like I think about
prisons policy a lot right we send far
too many people to prison for minor
offenses where and that's mostly men
because most of the people in prison are
men and that means that their lives are
completely trashed and they never manage
to come back out of that spiral of
graduating through bigger and bigger
crimes and then their institutional Eyes
Forever and the obvious solution to that
is send fewer people to prisons and
fewer men to prison for low-level
offenses have more Community punishments
and we know the reason that people don't
do that is because a very strong
right-wing press will crucify any
politician who does that anyone who
commits a rape while out on remand will
that you know the Polish knew was
responsible for that will get pilloried
in the Press but there's not that you
know there's not the thing that I know
what's the lever to pull and who's
stopping it being pulled in the case of
male suicide and that's what makes it
really really difficult it gets thrown
at feminists a lot about like what are
you doing about male suicide and the
answer is well not very much because no
one
no one seems to know what the thing is
that we need to be doing are you
familiar with Carl Soper do you know him
he wrote a book called The Evolution of
the life worth living no I don't the
whole thing I've got him coming on the
show at the start of next year so once
the episodes up I'll send it to you I
think you'd be really interested and he
conducted a study in which someone was
given the option of dating uh at two
different types of person
one of them had a single previous
suicide attempt and the other one
currently right now had cancer
on average people wanted the person that
had cancer
that's really an interesting finding his
I mean my theory behind it is that um
many almost all social reinforcement
mechanisms are there to stop people from
committing suicide to stop them from
taking their own life he sees depression
as not a precursor too but a defensive
mechanism against uh suicide most people
that commit suicide aren't actually
depressed it doesn't seem it seems that
people when you get depressed it
restricts the amount of movement and and
energy that you expend I haven't got
into the book sufficiently deeply so I
there may be areas of this that I'm
butchering because I remember it from a
half cut dinner three weeks ago when I
first learned about him
um but all of this is fascinating and my
point being that
it is such a
difficult
idiosyncratic
individual problem to try and look at
like why is it that any one person
arrives at the point where they decide
to do that
I don't know like the bit that I do
think we could probably do more about is
about cultivating men's social
relationships
um like I do think there is an
established thing that men particularly
when they get married if they're
straight they run all their kind of
social life and their social
relationships through their wife you
know the people like them you must know
some of those guys who just have no idea
when anyone in their family's birthday
is don't you know don't arrange to see
friends they just kind of they get
buffeted around and I I'm pretty sure
there's research that says that means
that Widow is struggle a lot more
actually than widows because they don't
have a kind of social sort of safety
support by them
um and it's one of the things I think
again like the internet is a kind of bit
of a problem with is that they also talk
about the fact that women talk to each
other and men to talk side by side with
each other right like you go fishing or
you go to the football or you go and do
something and then the conversation
happens in those spaces I think it's
harder maybe for men to like phone up
their mates and go like
can we just have a chat hand here mate
yeah did you read uh Billy no mates this
year by Max Dickens I didn't read it but
I heard about it yeah it sounded really
interesting really worthwhile oh you
could just listen to the podcast I did
with them and okay that's it that's all
to that problem yeah he he was really
great and he had a bunch of
suggestions that I've seen come from
women as well as guys Nina power and
Louise Perry both brought this solution
up and then so did Max and it was the
reintroduction of mail only spaces as
something which should be encouraged
again because there was
50 years ago the working Men's Clubs and
the halls of power that only men were
allowed into was seen as a vaulted room
in which the important decisions it
would fix and choose the Destiny for
women's lives were being made that
needed to be broken open so that men
were no longer the ones that were making
the decisions on behalf of women and
what that's in their opinion ended up
with is a removal of a lot of the
male-only spaces that allowed men to
bond in the way that they perhaps used
to and Max's research seems to show
precisely what you said a man gets into
a marriage and then transplants his
entire friend group with that of his
wife and then now he's just it's like
his wife's friends that are now his
friends but if they ever split up and
ever increasing divorce rates mean that
they might
he's now left with no wife and no
friends because all of the friends were
her friends they were friends with him
because of her but they're not friends
with him
yeah I think that's true that's
interesting about merely spaces I agree
with you the problem is that
you know when I think about that I think
about things like you know whether it's
the judges or going to the Garrick club
or whites or the private members club or
or equally well the thing that happened
you know within my lifetime which is
that the group of lawyers all go to the
strip club after work
um and those become ways in which men
Advance through the company
um and and women are locked out of
people with caring responsibilities
can't kind of go and do those things but
there is a I mean my dad was a member of
a working men's club which he used to
take me to put me in the Saloon bar give
me two pounds to put in the quiz machine
and tell me to like come you know just
keep earning it back to keep maintaining
myself
um while he was in the bar bar bit
um and I think that you know that was
something he got a great deal out of and
I think that was a fairly wholesome
space I very much doubt those people
were being wildly misogynist in there or
they were kind of scratching each
other's backs in a kind of
um nepotistic work way so I don't think
I'd be against that I mean it would be
very interesting to know whether or not
there'd be a huge backlash to that I
mean there's a huge backlash to the idea
of women-only spaces um so I don't know
what men only spaces would be seen as
well to the idea that women kind of are
gathering together
is seen as sort of innately kind of
um transgressive now and actually I I my
my opinions on this have slightly
changed to the extent that I think
probably I think there should only be
women only spaces now really for safety
like I'm not sure I would want to join a
women-only Club is that not just because
you don't want to be around that many
women you're they're not going to have
as interesting like what do you what's
what's your issue with race of women
come on I went to an all-girl school so
you know that doesn't put you off women
for life no I did but I did genuinely
get to University and I was like I'm
gonna be friends with men now and I
lived with male housemates and I've
always had loads of male friends ever
since
um but no I might say most of my close
friends are not sure if that's actually
true but like probably 50 50. but I I
just think actually that it obviously
upsets men horribly to be excluded from
women's spaces and so you should have
really clear Provisions about why those
spaces exist and and also that we're
kind of you know in lots of ways much
more than we were in the past much more
equal why do you still need Single Sex
bases but maybe I don't know the one
thing I do I interviewed Louise for the
spark and the thing I really disagree
with her on was this idea that women
shouldn't get drunk in mixed sex spaces
I was like I can't believe you're
advocating the existence of Saudi Arabia
like I'm listening to this this is
really Your solution and she said look
it's not like that at all it's you know
it's it's it's Norm you know normally
advice and I can see that that's true
actually there are a lot of situations
in which I wouldn't go out and get
completely drunk because I think it
would be irresponsible but it's
something about it just still really
really wrangles with me the idea that
we're gonna have to accept that forever
that men are so dangerous I I don't know
maybe I'm still slightly utopian I don't
know yeah well I mean David boss's Men
Behaving Badly it kind of showed me a
I don't make a uh Habit of hanging
around with sexual aggressors and sexual
offenders so learning from David that
it's a small minority of men committing
the vast majority of offenses repeatedly
that opened just learning that fact to
open my eyes oh just because I don't
know any people that act like that
doesn't mean that there can't be tons
and tons of crimes like that you don't
need like one man to one crime you can
have one man to a hundred crimes right
um I that's a difficult one I didn't
speak to Louise about that with the
mixed sex drinking spaces
coming from her background that uh women
that have been killed during rough sex
are Court thing I can't remember what
it's called that she worked for
um the rough sex defense yeah and we
can't consent to this yeah and I think
that's true that's the stuff that I do
agree on right like super sex positivity
stuff has been
you know I was writing in difficult
women about the idea that the sexual
liberation of the 60s was basically like
you have to be up for it all the time
and now you can't say no because that
means you're frigid and there is a
certain thing that now happens with
things like Freedom
yeah where it's like if you don't want
to get choked that's because you're some
up type [ __ ] and it's like it's really
very dangerous thing to do and as you
say there are a very small number of men
who will choke a woman to death and then
claim that that was totally consensual
and some of those cases are horrific
some of these cases people have got
multiple other injuries you've had
things shoved inside them and you just
think there probably has to be limits on
what we assume people can consent to
which is very paternalistic I agree like
again coming from the sort of body
modification sites of the 2000s you know
there was a famous case of the bottom
branding couple and all this sort of
stuff about whether or not you could
consent to s m and we've moved
incredibly far on that actually in the
British law in the last couple of
decades but I wonder if people are not
some creeping our knees is coming in
about that maybe what about Steve Jobs
what did you learn about him what about
Steve Jobs from consensual s m to Steve
Jobs as far as I can see
well I was interested in him anyway
because I've been writing this book
about genius which has a lot of overlaps
um with gurus in that who gets acclaimed
as a genius and who actually changes the
world are often not necessarily you know
it's a Venn diagram rather than a circle
and Steve Jobs was an incredibly good
marketer like he is of a type with
people like Thomas Edison or Elon Musk
in that he created
an aspiration and a lifestyle and
products that went with it and that is a
type of Genius totally but it is also
that he was a showman and I think that's
incredible but the thing that kind of
came up from us is that he was also
deeply interested in Indian spirituality
so at his funeral he gave everybody a
copy of autobiography of a yogi by
Yogananda
and he went to India in the 70s and
tried to find a guru of his own and was
into Primal scream therapy and mucusless
diets and we didn't get to put it in the
show but Dan cocky was like employee
number one for Apple told us that at one
point Steve went to the local Zen
Monastery with like a copy of the second
generation Mac and was like look this is
for you and this Zen monk was like I
don't believe in possessions what do you
what do you want from me here and he
just he just couldn't quite contemplate
anyone who wouldn't want one of his like
shiny new computers
um but you can definitely see that in
the whole aesthetic of Apple the kind of
clean lines of of it
um did you see him as a guru as well
well we had this conversation with
several people who knew him and one of
them said look he said if I ever turn
into a guru kill me but he kind of did
didn't he like he did kind of preach a
certain aesthetic and a lifestyle and
have a kind of people would refer to the
cult of Apple you know that they thought
they were more than computers they were
a representative of kind of you this
very cool San Francisco Bay tip young
Tech guy rather than a square Windows
user so he did in some respects make
himself a guru that doesn't mean that he
was a bad girl that he didn't achieve a
lot
um but yeah I think he was a guru when
it comes to people who've had influence
and changed the world and the
intersection of those what's your
thoughts on Jordan Peterson do you think
that he has influenced the world do you
think that he's just had influence
what's your opinion on that
well I've heard from a lot of John
Peterson fans having interviewed him
um and
there are lots of particularly young men
who really credit him for having given
them a narrative about their lives that
you know they could improve like of
self-improvement right that you do just
you tidy the bedroom you put the you
know you have the shower and the kind of
thing I find really sad about that is
the fact that there were some people
whom this was really useful advice and
you're thinking what has happened in
your life that you know have a shower
every morning and try and have some
self-respect is something that you
needed to hear from
you know not from your friends or family
but from someone outside that but
equally well
I'm really pleased that they got that so
my interactions yeah I've had some very
unpleasant there are still people who
are now
you know vandalizing my Wikipedia page
to this day because they're so angry
about that interview but there were also
some people who who really did take
guidance from him
the thing I do think about him
is that he was incredibly unsuited for
internet Fame psychologically and it's
sort of sadly ironic that he as a
psychologist kind of couldn't see that
because he got that thing where half the
people were telling him he was the
Messiah and he'd saved them and they're
coming up to him and half the people
were kind of like you said earlier
treating him like the devil and he just
wasn't able to tune out that noise and
be himself and find himself somewhere in
that bubble and I think it really really
got to him
um would he not say that it was more the
stress of wife being ill Downstream from
that like a lot of personal things I
mean layering on top of that the
pressure of the of the public world but
he as far as I'm aware doesn't usually
attribute it much to what's going on
publicly it was almost all what was
going on privately do you not think that
that's right well he did say that
recently that being in Twitter was like
people sort of shouting at you 24 7
which is you know pretty good experience
uh the most malignant form of telepathy
where all that you ever hear are the
shittest of everybody else's thoughts
yeah that's probably you is that the
same one when he later had this phrase
that I absolutely loved in his podcast
which was we're frolicking in the ruins
of our was it we're frolicking in the
ruins of our shared epistemology maybe
that's which is
wow okay
okay say those words in that order or
not on a podcast well done Sam but yeah
I I'm not
I know that's what he says but he has
come up with several different versions
of the cider vinegar story
um and the you know and the strange beef
based diet story but yeah I don't no one
goes through their partner being
diagnosed with a potentially
life-threatening cancer
um and you know through his dependence
on benzodiazepines you know those are
things that I think would challenge even
the kind of strongest David willing
would have an issue getting through that
let alone somebody who'd already been
pretty stressed it suffered from
clinical depression all of his life as
as far as he knew so yeah I have great
personal Symphony with but I also think
it's sort of ironic that somebody was a
great Guru of personal responsibility
doesn't seem to be able to stop tweeting
just tweeting constantly day and night
now he's back on Twitter and it's
clearly not good for him
um because he's just getting angry with
random Anonymous people online and you
know I do sort of I I absolutely underst
I have had my moments of arguing with
random people online and I know what
it's like when you I think people use it
as a form of self-harm to some extent
social media like that you know that
people are going to come back and say
horrible things to you and you sort of
do it anyway knowing that like I do
think that is a kind of strange adult
version of slicing up your arms with a
razor blade
um and it's it's a real shame that he
can't
stop himself really because there are
like you know I talked to David Fuller
for this
um for one of the episodes and he really
loved you know the jungian perspectives
he really loved his attempt to
synthesize all these interesting
traditions of psychoanalysis and all the
stuff he would write about story
structure and stuff like that there was
obviously a lot of intellectual content
that was not cultural War related in
Jordan Peterson and I you know I'm not a
personally a massive fan but that I to
me that was the best of him and he's not
doing that anymore is he he's doing
he's he's or at least his attention
seems to be on the worst bits of his
personality the bits that I like the
least I guess was I I would certainly
say I would be a good avatar for one of
those people
not necessarily to clean up your room I
think I'd thankfully managed your room
looks delightful I have to say yeah so
what the advice has worked thank you
um however there was a good bit of stuff
I was the prototypical 28 year old guy
manchilding his way through a world that
gave him success that Society said he
should enjoy and yet hadn't found the
Fulfillment that he thought that he
should do and you know tell the truth
that was the first time that anybody had
said that that was something that I
really really should focus on not like
as an arbitrary it's the honest and good
thing to do but like this is actually
something that you can aim for and I'm
like wow like that's really
that's very very interesting and then
you see Sam writes the book lying which
is basically kind of the same thing but
from a more philosophical kind of
pragmatic side and then extreme
ownership and it comes out from Joker
willink and you go okay like everybody's
converging on this same thing but Jordan
was the whatever the gateway drug for me
with that but I also know what you mean
when it comes to someone using
like overusing Twitter and getting into
a rhythm of being adversarial on there
any time that I ever end up getting
tagged in a thread with Chris Kavanagh
I know that checking Twitter for the
next 24 hours is pointless because my
notifications no matter even if I have a
tweet that goes Super viral they're
going to be dominated by his argument
with this person who has an egg for a
profile like that's he will not let it
go if there's an argument that to be had
like Chris's Irish heritage will win out
and he will continue to like they're a
war they're a resilient bunch and um
yeah I personally I don't understand it
I mean I I like Chris and awful lot I
think he's a great guy but I don't have
I do not share his desire to correct
people who are wrong on the internet in
fact you may be able to see up there I
have the xkcd cartoon which is like you
know the one which is the famous one of
come to bed I can't someone is wrong on
the internet that was to me a time in my
life that I'm very happy to have to have
left behind I guess
um it's habituated though right you know
you get yourself in the Rhythm you'll
have done this you have these sort of
micro habit routines where I know for a
period of time there's a particular book
or whatever that you're obsessed with or
or you start a new pursuit or do you
there's a TV series or something and for
a three-month period at five PM every
night you'll be late making tea or late
doing something because you start doing
something else playing pickleball or
[ __ ] knitting or whatever it is that
you end up doing and I think that you
know the feedback mechanism and the
dopamine hijack that you get from
Twitter means that if that's what you've
got yourself locked in on they can
really really be compelling and if there
is always a a battle to be had uh it's a
it's a big Temptation so yeah I mean
it'll be interesting though isn't it
don't you think about it exactly the
same way that you think about bad food
which is that it is initially delicious
and it feels so good when you're eating
you know when you're eating the
McDonald's you're like oh the Big Mac
why don't I only eat Big Macs this is
amazing and then you notice that you're
immediately hungry again and then you
feel profoundly sad about your life
choices and you know and so I you know I
do eat junk food I eat junk food
occasionally but I I know that I
wouldn't want to eat a junk food only
diet because I would feel like you know
not even any moral qualms I would just
feel worse in myself I would feel
unnourished and so much in my project in
journalism over the last 10 years has
been about trying to find to do the
things that are genuinely you know not
porridge exactly but like a nice like a
nice poke bowl like a nice you know
healthy balanced diet and and part of
that is I think podcasts are really good
for that because you you do end up
having a conversation you know I'm sure
some of your opinions on topics like
gender in a slightly different place to
mine but we're just going to end up
having I'm going to listen to everything
that you say and take it as part of you
as a human and then I'm going to kind of
offer my kind of bits that I do and
don't agree with rather than it turning
into some kind of
sort of Christian and the lines dunking
Bloodsport where all my feminist fans
come out and turn up and tell you that
you're a huge misogynist and all your
bro fans come up and tell me that I'm a
kind of unfuckable Harpy and we both
have to kind of go back off back off
people back off
um so we can actually have this
conversation right like that's we're
cold today that's how it goes
cultivating a reasonable audience is is
an incredibly difficult thing to do on
the Internet it's like it's it's one of
the hardest things to do
um and like I don't even know what the
term would be disciplining the audience
or guiding them towards it is like it
does feel like this you mean it is like
animal training is the sort of community
that I want to have I want it to be
respectful I want it to be
um thoughtful I want it to be nuanced I
wanted to be insightful I wanted to be
patient I want it to be like all of
these things and yet the stuff that
compels people to comment and none of
those insights and then every so often
there'll be this really amazing comment
that'll come up on the YouTube I'll be
like heart it and like get it as high
because there's certain things you can
do to sort of push it push it further up
I'm like look this this this is the
Shrine of the type of discussion that I
want to have it's polite it's
disciplined it's blah blah blah it's all
of those things
and yet the internet is you know
publicly open to anybody that has the
biggest grievance and the most number of
capital letters available on their
keyboard so yeah I I think it's very
very interesting thinking about the the
secular gurus thing I think it's very
timely for you to release this at the
moment especially off the back of
um very bad Wizards conspirituality uh
decoding the gurus you know those are
For Better or Worse the like Insider
baseball like the The Rock star's
favorite bands I think it's a guilty
pleasure like some of those most
podcasters that I know listen to one of
those shows in one form or another
because they kind of keep their finger
on the pulse of what's happening and
what's the other one q and on Anonymous
and like other stuff like that
everybody's got like some finger in one
of those pies
I think that the discussion about
secular gurus is an interesting one
and I think that it's probably pretty
timely to to start talking about it so
I'm looking forward to coming out uh
where should people go
if they want to check out this series
and can people outside of the UK yes
listen yes we can so it's a BBC um Radio
4 on BBC sounds uh project so it comes
out in two drops one on the 19th of
December the first four episodes and
then the next four after that but it is
also available wherever you find your
podcasts awesome and why should people
go if they want to check out Mario stuff
but I mean we got pretty much everywhere
I've been all over the place Chris let
me let me tell
me 10 tickets where it is my main
writing home they are currently in the
middle of sending me to write a long
piece about Florida which is great I
love Florida I'm uh in the tank for
Florida it is a great American state and
I saw a manatee I fired a gun I did
everything that you would want to do in
Florida and um yeah and that's the kind
of decadent Journal lifestyle that I'm
living at the moment fantastic all right
Helen thank you thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]